pearls
nature's beauty and for centuries man's
obsession
until recently distinguishing a natural
from a cultured pearl was relatively
simple something that could be done by a
trained eye but that's changed a farmed
pearl and a natural one and now almost
indistinguishable while at the same time
the price between the two has widened in
Zurich Johanna works as a researcher at
the Swiss Federal Institute of
Technology and had developed new
techniques for testing pearls her
process obtains DNA and is regarded as a
game-changer when we can read it it
tells us a lot of information side for
example from which pearl oyster it comes
from from which species it's an oyster
from the arriving golfer or from
Australia or from China and so on
Michel heads a professional team
employed to deal with thousands of
pieces of pearl jewelry that arrive for
certification much of it very expensive
he says the large amount of cultured
pearls flooding the market increases the
value of antique natural pearls so we
have especially from China huge amounts
of freshwater cultured pearls and they
are very cheap generate so you talk
about hundred dollars maybe a few
hundred dollars or even less and we have
on the other side a very much in ishe
markets of natural pearls very often
also historical items where there were
no cultured pearls at that time and
these pearls have gone up in price
tremendously in the last few years there
is like a boom in this market I have to
say
Angus Bennett Bloomberg